نعتقد أنه يجب تشغيل الروبوتات
كمشغلي خدمة وأول
مكان للبدء هو المكان الذي يعلق فيه الناس
مئات الأقدام في الهواء في
اسكتلندا الروبوتات ، لدينا روبوت
ينظف النوافذ ، لذلك إذا نظرنا إلى مبنى مكون من 40
طابقًا به تقريبًا  300000
قدم مربع من سطح النافذة
لتنظيفها ، سيستغرق العمل القياسي اليوم
ما يقرب من شهرين ونصف من
العمل الفعلي للتنظيف ومع Osmo ومشرفين اثنين فقط
يمكننا القيام بنفس العمل في
حوالي أسبوع ، حيث تطابق الروبوت فعليًا
مع المبنى في  ثلاثي الأبعاد يقترب من
المباني ، كل عقبة قد
تكون مثل رأس يخرج من النافذة
أو النافذة التي تفتح الروبوت سوف
يصحح نفسه بنفسه ويتحرك حوله حتى
لا يكسر نافذة كيف يعرف
ما إذا كان شخص ما يخرج رأسه بشكل
جيد  لديها رؤية كمبيوتر وأجهزة استشعار تعمل باللمس
حتى نتمكن من رؤيتها في هذا المجال ،
أعتقد أن أول ما يفكر فيه الناس
عندما يرون هذا النوع من النظام
هو الأتمتة قادمة لوظائفنا
وهذا على الأرجح  يبدو
أنه المثال المثالي لأولئك الأشخاص الذين ربما
لا يحصلون على أجور عالية في تنظيف هذه
المباني ، سيتم استبدالهم
بهذا الروبوت جيدًا ، أعتقد أن
المجتمع البشري في نهاية المطاف سيحل محل
الوظائف الخطرة لأنه ليس من
المنطقي أن يكون الناس كذلك  المخاطرة
بحياتهم من حيث نقف عندما ننظر
إلى الوظيفة التي نقوم بأتمتها ، فمن
المنطقي تمامًا بالنسبة لنا أن نضع الشخص
في وضع آمن يشرف على
الروبوتات ونترك الروبوتات تتدلى
مئات الأقدام في الهواء.